let's go to John from Kentucky John
what's going on
I can it
it sounds like you're underwater you're
not underwater are you
I'm not ready oh boy you did you say
you're not underwater right now
I'm not underwater right this moment but
now it sounds all it sounds so much
better what did you just change
I just went off of my car Bluetooth to
my hands up beautifully done beautifully
done what's on your mind today
yeah I just had a I had a question
um I've been I'm an Uber driver and I
talk a lot of politics in the car which
is a mistake I gotta say yeah but um a
question that's kind of been popping up
as a 25 year old left this is just I
just what's the point in conservatism
anymore
I I mean I'm not gonna I can't answer
that for you that's interesting so like
let me see if I can understand the
situation you drive Uber in Kentucky
and so are most of your passengers right
Wingers
well I I actually live in uh Louisville
Kentucky so we're a blue dot in a red
State okay so I get a good mix of people
so I'll have a lot of leftists in the
car I'll have a lot of liberals and then
a lot of the people that I get are
Republican yeah and I I just simply like
one of the things that I've been saying
recently
um I don't know if you've ever watched
Adventure Time no I don't even know what
it is
okay Adventure Time is an is a kids show
it was really really good though uh
there's this there was this uh vampire
lady named Marceline and in one of the
episodes she's fighting this other guy
who's the vampire King and they break
apart and the vampire King is like hey
Marceline you've lived over a thousand
years what have you learned and she says
something to the effect of
um you know everybody keeps making the
same mistakes over and over again and I
guess nobody lives long enough to see
the pattern right and well listen my
thought on that is as follows and I
don't want to interrupt the retelling of
Adventure Time episodes but here's my
thought there's two things going on with
conservatism one is the idea of let's
keep doing things the way we've done
them before just for the sake of
continuing to do them the same way we've
done them before which for me isn't a
very good argument necessarily right and
then also there is a sort of
contrarianism to conservatism when
people from typically from the left say
hey here's an advancement that we have
which will improve things there's like a
reflexive contrarianism where it's just
like no no no no no we're not going to
do that just because you want to we're
not going to do it so I think that those
are two important elements of it
hey 100 and like you know one of the
things I've been saying a lot in the car
is respectfully I don't have to have
lived a thousand years to see that the
story of human history has always been
conservatives or their historical
contemporaries fighting against progress
yeah and then leftists or their
historical contemporaries dragging them
Kicking and Screaming into that progress
so yeah I just don't see the yeah it's
just frustrating living in in red state
right now what can I say John what's the
wackiest Uber driving situation you've
experienced
oh
um uh honestly I haven't had too many
bad red I did have one lady get in the
car with the Maga hat and the flags and
the the pins and stuff and we're about
two minutes into the ride and she just
casually says you know I just can't
stand the way the media treats true
patriot right and so I kind of give it a
second and I'm like okay I'll bite who
are true Patriots and she says well Matt
Gates Alex Jones just to name a couple
yeah I'm like oh okay well I don't have
to say Alex Jones is full of crap you
know he says that in depositions and
stuff but uh Matt Gates the guy who's
currently under investigation from the
doj for child sex trafficking like this
is the guy who's a true patriot too
really have you ever had to kick anyone
out of the car
um I have not but I think that's mostly
because my demeanor in the car is very
much if you don't like it you can walk
so I think that more kind of like that
keeps people in line a lot of the time
so yeah well John I appreciate the call
uh stay safe out there
I'll try brother thank you all right uh
congratulations on the new child thank
you there's John from Kentucky with some
powerful powerful declarations as a
reminder if you want the uh opportunity
to get on to chat with me and you are
currently in the Discord waiting Lobby
your nickname must be name and where
you're calling from it doesn't even have
to be real like I don't know where you
really are but it has to be in that
format so people who just have like
single word nicknames and stuff like
that you're not going to get called on
just as a heads up so everybody knows
and is on the same page let's go to Alex
from Seattle Alex welcome
morning David
um I wanted to ask you about a book
written by a guest who had on a few
months ago Bobby azarian sure that was
called the romance of reality yeah
did you did you read the book I read
part of it yeah for that one I read uh
like I often do introduction table of
contents first chapter last chapter and
some stuff in between
okay interesting um I found it to be I
went up first off I wanted to thank you
for having that guest on and having that
book I've in the process of reading it
and I've I'm reading it slowly because
um it's a very dense book I'm sure if
you read a couple of chapters you
probably like it's it's very um it's
explaining each piece as it goes
building its case for you know uh uh you
know why why why do we exist what is
life for
um I just wanted to know if you you if
in the brief parts that you read if
there was anything you found to be
um either disagreeable or if it changed
anything about how you thought about
Concepts like Free Will determinism
because it goes into a lot of that no I
mean you know when I I read so much that
it's rare at this point that I read
something and it completely upends my
view it's just sort of like it now
averages in to My Views overall and just
like can slightly tweak things so I
don't know that I can say that there was
any kind of like big 180 that I did as a
result of the parts of the book that I
read but it certainly presented and so
did the interview you know you I I think
my view tends to be there is really no
one source that describes reality to as
far as I'm concerned what I'm looking
for are
thoughtful
ideas to integrate into my understanding
so no I can't say I had any real 180s
okay did you I mean is there something
you read in the book that made you say
wow yeah I mean prior to reading the
book I mean I um I really kind of
believed in the concept of determinism
it seemed to make the most sense to me
yeah you know ball rolling down a hill
add more complexity you know start to
finish I I feel like that kind of worked
and especially with like more
Progressive politics you can use that
lens and you can look at the way
people's lives exist and the problems
they run into and you can use that and
the way the book presents it is kind of
you know it basically
takes things like life and it says
instead of it being a thing that just
kind of magically happened and it's like
a miracle it frames it as like it as an
inevitability based on fundamental laws
of Science and it continues to build
from there and so I found that it it
really made me rethink it made me
believe in free will again if that kind
of makes sense
um because it frames it as as uh you
know the concept of Free Will is the
ability to imagine uh possible realities
and then steer yourself there and um
anyway I just I I found it to be a
fascinating book I recommended highly as
someone who does not consider themselves
religious
um I found it to be a thing that
explained the universe in a way that
kind of gave it a purpose that kind of
made sense so and I was just I was very
surprised at that because I'm highly
skeptical you know similar to your your
perspective around a lot of things I was
surprised at how much I connected with
the book and found it to be interesting
well I appreciate the feedback Alex
thank you I would love to have more
authors like that on your show we will
make it happen
all right all right thanks Alex take
care very always great to hear that
people are getting value from uh from
the the guests on the show that's
fantastic